(upbeat music)
[Nellie] My bridesmaid entrances
are the stuff of legends.
Ever, the bridesmaid.
That is my badge of honor.
You feel me?
[Conor] I feel you.
♪ We were young ♪
[Nellie] I go to weddings
and baby showers
every damn weekend.
[Richard] When are you gonna
gimme grandkids?
- Talk to your firstborn
about grandchildren.
- I don't want him procreating.
[Jesse] No.
- That's a terrifying thought.
- Yeah, nobody wants that.
- Nobody wants that.
- I don't have a man
or any legit prospects.
What have I ever done?
Am I not suitable for life?
[Sheila] You are very
suitable for life.
- I feel like I'm running
out of time.
[Monroe] Are you seeing
anyone now?
- I'm seeing everyone now.
It's sort of an all
you can eat buffet.
- How old are you?
Please say 32 or 33.
Nellie?
- I'm 34.
(slap smacks)
- Stupid.
♪ Let's make a run for it ♪
- I want you to remember they
can be in Never-Neverland,
never growing up, never aging.
But those eggs, they are.
(cheerful music)
- If I don't spend
13K to freeze my eggs,
I might never be
able to have kids.
Meanwhile, you're gonna
wait 'til you're 70
to have a baby
with an influencer.
- That is accurate
and I'm not
embarrassed about it.
[Sara] What's new
with you, Nellie?
- I'm thinking about
getting my eggs frozen.
- That's amazing!
- Maybe I should
have a baby shower.
[Jen] But you're not
having a baby.
(cheerful music)
- What if I screw this up?
I don't even know
if I want kids.
I've seen "Euphoria."
[Nurse Ali] You're not
gonna screw this up.
(Nellie cheers)
♪ I love me ♪
♪ Gonna love myself,
no, I don't need ♪
- You're buying time.
Someone who's good enough
for you is hard to come by.
♪ No, I don't need
anybody else ♪
- I'm either going
through a Renaissance or
amidst the worst
crisis of my lifetime.
♪ I love me ♪
[Doctor] Here we go.
Down here,
and you look like, I'd say...
- Virgin?
- (chuckles) Definitely not.
Okay.
♪ I love me ♪